Secretary of State Mike Pompeo is headed
back to the US after meeting with top
Saudi and Turkish officials about the
disappearance of Washington Post
contributor Jamal khashoggi Turkish
officials claim they have proof that a
15 member Saudi hit squad killed
khashoggi inside Saudi Arabia's
consulate in Istanbul they have yet to
release that proof Robin Wright has
covered the Middle East for more than
four decades and written eight books
about the region she's a contributing
writer for The New Yorker and a longtime
friend of Jamal khashoggi robinred good
morning thanks for joining us good
morning I know you last spoke with Jamal
in August and he was worried about his
life what did he tell you about why he
may think that the Saudis and the crown
prince would want him dead well he said
that Saudis wanted him out of the
picture he had become over the past year
one of the most outspoken and most
visible Saudi dissidents an odd position
for a man who actually still supported
the monarchy but he had begun to call
the current Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman the most autocratic leader of all
six kings who have ruled since the
founder of Saudi Arabia died in 1953 and
this was clearly a line that went too
far so he was also critical not just of
the crown prince but if the crown
prince's father absolutely he was
critical of this particular line of the
royal family remember that since the
crown prince was appointed last year the
king has effectively created a whole new
royal family from thousands and
thousands of princes who all felt that
they deserved whether it was a piece of
power or some of the perks and privilege
of the monarchy Robin what was the
nature of the criticism and how did that
if differ from you know there's been
criticism for years about the u.s.
relationship with Saudi Arabia and so
why and how is this different well this
is a turning point I think between the
United States and Saudi Arabia and you
think of just six months ago the crown
prince was touring whether it was
Harvard Hollywood or Houston he was
faded by some of the most luminary names
in technology industry and the movie
industry and this is a moment where his
place his power within the kingdom is
actually being questioned and that was
something
that Jamal had accomplished in his
disappearance that he hadn't been able
to do in his life Robert what are your
thoughts about how President Trump is
handling this Robin even floating the
idea of rogue killers well he's the he's
the first one to float that idea and
he's really taken a an enormous gamble
three of his most important objectives
anywhere in the world are in the Middle
East and he's invested particularly in
the crown prince whether it's on the
Illusive Middle East peace plan
counterterrorism in the age of Isis or
squeezing Iran into changing his
behavior or even changing the regime
itself and so this is a real challenge
for his foreign policy as well as
relationship with Kingdom Robin there
have been calls from many foreign an
independent investigation people saying
the Saudis can't investigate themselves
don't know how much they can rely on the
Turkish authorities what do you think
there is no Bob Mueller in the kingdom
and the challenge for the legitimacy of
any report is finding someone who is
going to tell something that even begins
to resemble the truth there is no
independent judiciary and in fact the
crown prince over the past 16 months has
consolidated all five vectors of sectors
of power economic military in the royal
court it's very hard to find someone
who'll dissent Robin because you know so
much about the Middle East I think there
is another sub context of this entire
story beyond Jamal khashoggi and his
alleged murder there why is Turkey
leaking these details what's Turkey's
relationship with the Saudis what do
they want from the Saudis is Qatar
involved in this at all
well it's a really interesting power
play between two of the most significant
players in the region Turkey and Saudi
Arabia have been rivals for power and in
the Gulf and in in many ways
interpreting what how Islam and politics
intersect so this will play out on
levels that have far more repercussions
than just Saudi Arabia the United States
it'll play out across the region all
right Robin right thanks so much